Hey Brian, you're back from vacation, huh?
So I heard a lot about these
Squidward Games, and I have to write something
about it. Can you fill me in?
Can I! So, you’ve got this guy
Gi-hun. He's kind of your average,
everyday dirtbag who gives his
daughter a gun for her tenth birthday.
Wait, what? A gun?
Relax: it's just for lighting cigarettes!
So he's deep in debt with loan sharks,
but then one day an angel comes
along and throws him a lifeline.
Sounds uplifting!
It is! You ever play pogs when you were a kid?
Pogs, yeah I played it!
Okay, so you know the rules: Somebody
gives you eight dollars every time
you win. And if you lose, they
get to slap you in the face.
What?
Slap-pogs!
Is he good at Slap-Pogs?
He's not great. So naturally after he gets slapped
for several hours and finally wins eight dollars,
he does what any of us would do: He gives
himself over to a mysterious organization,
allows himself to be kidnapped and drugged,
and says yes to literally anything.
Sort of like that week I
spent at the Improv Olympics.
Yes, and?
So anyway, there's a lot of colorful
characters playing these Squid Games.
Like who, for example?
Well, you’ve got Gi-hun, of
course. You got Gi-hun’s mean,
smart friend with the glasses. You got old
Snake Face, who's got the snakiest face
of the whole lot of 'em. You’ve got Crazy Toilet Lady and
her maybe imaginary kids. You’ve got Stabby,
who’ll stab her way out of anything
if you give her a sharp object, or
even a blunt one. And, of course, you’ve got
A Harmless Old Man Who Isn’t Hiding Anything.
I like the sound of that last guy!
So what sorts of games do they play?
Well, do you remember playing
“Red Light, Green Light” as a kid?
Yes! But not with any slapping.
Brian!
Don't worry, red light green light is a slap-free zone.
Okay, cool.
Instead, when the big robot lady turns her head
around and she says red light and you so much
as move an eyebrow the wrong way, a sniper rifle
blows half your head clean off! It's super fun.
What?
It’s partly to illustrate just how
brutal this whole squid game is,
and partly to cut down on background
extras in your pilot episode so your
craft services budget doesn’t spiral out of control. Anyway,
after that, everyone leaves the game because
they realize it’s a brutal exercise in futility.
Oh, thank God.
But right after that, they all figure
out they live horrible garbage lives,
so they just join the game again, and it takes
forty-five entire minutes of on-screen
misery for everyone to get to that point.
Oh. Cool.
So, we've already established you’re
familiar with “Red Light, Green Light.”
Right, not that version, but-
Well, they play a lot of other
classic childhood games too!
This Squid Game has everything: Tug Of
War, Carve Sugar Good Or You’ll Die,
Murder Marbles, Exploding Glass Bridge, Do
All Of The Stabbing Before Anybody Else Can…
Monopoly?
Be serious, man. They’re not total monsters.
So the players fall one-by-one:
Snake Face, Crazy Toilet Lady, A Harmless
Old Man Who Isn't Hiding Anything, Stabby. Stabby dies.
Oh no, not Stabby. How does she die?
It's kind of a great twist. She gets stabbed.
Sure. She who lives by the stab
must also die by the stab. I guess.
This is so bad.
Uh-huh.
This is the absolute worst.
Yeah mhm.
Can you believe how awful this is?
Not really.
Who would ever want to actually watch
this, let alone pay money for it?
Wait, I thought you liked this?
Oh, I loved it! Those are the
names of episodes 4 through 7.
wakka wakka
So that takes us to our titular Squid Game. There
are two players left. Gi-Hun, and his mean
friend with glasses. Only — and here's another
great twist — he ain't got his glasses no more.
What happened to his glasses?
Who gives a s---, Brian? I'M TRYING
TO TELL YOU ABOUT THE SQUID GAME!
Okay! So, what is the Squid Game?
Well it's this game where they run around
for some reason, sometimes on one foot,
sometimes on two foots, on a
court that's shaped like a squid.
Shaped like a squid?
Yeah! You know, a triangle, a circle, oh, let's not forget a square.
I don't…
A squid! You know, like when you were
a kid, you used to live in a squid with
your parents until they kicked you out
for what kept happening in the bathroom,
so now you and three other
dudes share a studio angelfish?
I’m hanging up.
I’ll give you eight bucks to keep listening
Go on.
So Gi-Hun wins, his buddy dies,
and the Squidwards set him free and pay
him the billions he's earned by not dying.
What about that old man?
Which one?
The innocent old man who isn’t hiding anything?
Oh! It turns out that those were HIS squid games!
Sure. Wait, so they pay Gi-Hun the money?
Yeah.
Why don’t they just kill him?
I dunno.
Why don’t they dump him on
the street and then not pay him?
I dunno.
It’s just that it seems like this whole
thing is an unnecessarily long buildup to
a shaky conclusion that doesn't hold up to
even a single second of narrative scrutiny.
He wears a funny red wig at the end!
I'm just really confused about —
Listen, friend. It’s not the plot that matters
so much as the message. The message is that if
you gamble and lose and gamble and lose and gamble
and lose and gamble and lose and then you gamble
and then you lose and your wife leaves you because
you gamble and lose so much and then you gamble
and then you lose again and then someone says
“would you like to gamble,” there’s a pretty
good chance that you’re going to be okay. Maybe.
Or you’ll die! It’s one of those. Brian? Brian?
Bri-Bri?
Guess I get to keep my eight bucks.